jeff what is an enneagram and how does
it help a writer
create complex characters the enneagram
is a
really valuable tool it's a personality
profiling system that is a
mix of ancient wisdom about human nature
and cutting-edge psychology i was
introduced to it
by a friend of mine who was a
top psychiatrist in new york city
and he was a good friend and he loved
movies so
he loved to consult on projects that i
was working on
so like if i was developing a script
with a client i would often bring him in
uh like one time i brought
the actor john leguizamo to him he was
working on
um a murder story
and he wanted some in-depth
stuff the kind of stuff that armond
could bring
and he met with armand and i talked to
john afterwards
and uh armand had sat him down
in front of police video
of a guy who had just murdered his
parents 45 minutes beforehand
this was real footage and john said oh
my
god it messed me up i was like i
couldn't sleep that night and i was like
whoa and i said well was it good
research it goes off
top shelf like off the charts crazy
and i worked with armond a lot that way
and at one point he said to me because
he was doing uh
character profiles on these at one point
he said to me have you ever checked out
the enneagram it's the best thing out
there
i'd never heard of it before and coming
from him he was
really brilliant and really at the top
of his game
and for him to say it's the best thing
out there i was like
whoa it wasn't like oh i think i'll
check it i was like boom i was like
right on it and i studied it intensively
for a couple years
and it what it it purports that there's
nine
basic personality types and
each of them has their own uh
basic fears basic desires motivations
preferences tendencies
weaknesses flaws and
there's all these different and not only
all
that but each of the nine types
has different aspects like they're
either
a healthy aspect an average aspect or an
unhealthy aspect
and
depending on what
shape you're in emotionally and
psychologically
you are your life is either coming
together
you're you're integrating or your life
is falling apart you're disintegrating
and if you if you are
coming together as a person emotionally
and psychologically
then you will tend to exhibit the
average to healthy aspects
of the type you are
if you are falling apart as a person
then you will tend to exhibit the
average to unhealthy aspects
of that personality type
so it is a um
and they say that the average person
flickers between all those all day long
where you can have extremely healthy
reactions or actions in certain
situations or
extremely unhealthy and you flicker back
and forth all day long like real people
in and out of different emotional states
and so on
but you will tend to be what you are in
other words if you tend to be healthy
then most of your stuff will tend to be
average to healthy
and it is a
so like the nine types are like
um they give them labels but they don't
use the labels very much type 1 they
call
the reformer type 2 is the helper type 3
is the achiever
type 4 is the individualist type 5 is
the thinker or the they have different
names
type six is the loyalist type seven is
the enthusiast type eight is the leader
or the challenger
type nine is the peacemaker but
because each of those labels has certain
connotations with different people
the people who work with it
professionally they'll call you a one or
a four or a seven
because it's context free in a certain
way
the labels don't bring
their own misunderstandings to people
who are less
skilled in the application of the of the
technique
so that like a type three the achiever
can be very high performing it'll be
like a tony robbins type where they
really work hard to actualize all their
best
capabilities tom cruise is a type three
people who can really achieve great
things
push themselves to be the best they can
be and can really be extraordinary
but in the unhealthy or in the average
aspects
they can be really concerned with how
they appear
they're constantly wanting to look good
even if they aren't
doing well emotionally in the unhealthy
aspects they can
actively lie to look good even when
they're in really rough shape they're
really over concerned with how they
appear and will
do even devious things to maintain that
appearance
so that in the extremely unhealthy
aspects they can even be suicidal
or murderous to maintain the illusion of
their superiority or achieve
their achievements even if they're not
there
so
in terms of the
in both the creation of a character and
the development and dimensionalization
of a character
these the
the the basic human nature
which is built into the study of the
enneagram and
the cutting edge psychology which is
built into it
inform
what you both
find in your character and can
create in your character for instance if
i
uh like for instance going back to your
it guide derek and
the young woman skyler
uh i would one of the things i'd be
looking at and i'd be doing that once i
get a dilemma up and running
i'm also looking in the early stages of
developing a dilemma
for derek i would
go very quickly to which enneagram type
is he
because that's going to inform so much
who he is and how he interacts with his
dilemma and what his basic fears and
basic desires
and tendencies and motivations and
disabilities and flaws and blind spots
all of that inform not only what the
dilemma is
but how he will interact with it because
of his basic fears and drives and all
that
so let's see if i'm looking at him might
he be a one the reformer
it's possible two the helper maybe three
the achiever
possible for the individual list
possible because he is an individualist
can be
uh intuitive artistic want to sort out
their own emotions before they deal with
anything else
uh possibly a type five
a thinker a you know someone who is
perfecting things before they launch out
sherlock holmes was
a type 5 wants to have everything
like a type 4 wants to
figure out their emotional stuff before
they move ahead a type 5 wants to
figure out the mechanics of a situation
and have a lot of knowledge
because their basic fear is that they're
not well prepared
so they're protecting themselves so they
want to know everything before they
take a step so they spend too much time
figuring out before they take action
so they can be extremely world-changing
when they're on top of their game
and see things in a completely fresh way
but they can also be paranoid and
reclusive and
dissociated from who they really are
because they're desperately trying to
figure it all out in their head before
they do their debut
um so maybe he's a five he could be a
sixth the loyalist
which is lends itself to the it was the
guard
watchdog for this mainframe and the
whole company
the type one of the main motivating
factors in a type
six is they are
constantly hoping that the next person
they
latch onto is going to be the one who
can show them how to navigate life
successfully
are you the one can you help me
learn how to make my life work which
see that goes with the watchdog
for the corporation but also skyler like
are you the one that's going to show me
how to
make my life work finally so a six is a
possibility
a four is a possibility because
the um a four is
inwardly tuned has a lot of artistic
sensitivities
and a lot of inner debate
and wants to
make things work at an emotional level
uh i'm not describing it accurately
enough
but this is really an overview too but a
four is an interesting possibility
for derrick a six is an interesting
possibility
a seven the enthusiast is the
busy fun-loving type which could be a
very interesting possibility
for uh skyler someone who's like
wildly enthusiastic the life of the
party
always busy a healthy seven is a lot of
fun
an unhealthy seven can be a drug addict
they're a constant escapist mode
a seven's main motivation
is to um in the unhealthy aspect of
their fears they wanna
they wanna what's the word kind of
dispel
unease they can't sit
and deal with
emotional complexity they want to escape
from it they
they don't have the the bone that
enables them to sit there
and figure it out they're in escape mode
a lot if they're average to unhealthy
so they're always looking for the next
thing they're always planning even if
they've spent three months planning a
big cruise with all their friends
they can't enjoy the cruise because
they're busy planning the next thing
it's always about their plans
but they can be really fun to be around
and a healthy seven is really fun and a
really
healthy happy integrated person
so i would think that she's gonna be
pretty unhealthy
but they look dazzlingly fun
especially to someone who is feeling
miserable and
trapped and caught in a rut and no way
out
so it's kind of an interesting chemical
connection where her malfunction
meshes with his malfunction in a way
that she looks like his savior
and he may look like her savior
so they sink on a lot of levels and
they fit each other's compulsive pattern
in a certain way
that even though it's an unhealthy
relationship they get a lot of mileage
out of it before the each realizes that
wow i'm back where i started or worse
because he's just as messed up as i am
in a completely different way
and we really screwed this thing up you
know it's that kind of thing
so in many ways it's a mixture of what
you bring
to the picture with your story and
what the enneagram offers as
possibilities
for character traits and
possibilities for character
you you when you come with your story
you have
a certain amount of something already
you're not coming with nothing and just
looking at the enneagram
for instance with the story of derek
you've already got a raw story and
we've done some work with dilemma so
you've got him
trapped and then if you find that
he seems like a type six enneagram
then the tendencies and basic fears
and all the things that make up a six
influence your story and your story
influences how you use those parts of
the enneagram
for instance if you are
looking at the mechanics of a type 6
and it offers some dynamic possibilities
for what derek might be like as he
falls apart in a crucial moment of the
story
then that could really inform
the story choices that you make
and the story choices that you make can
inform what parts of the enneagram
you use or amplify or
play with you know so much of it is an
experimental
mix as you're really working with
everything
to gel
that which you decide to run with
one of the key ways that i use the
enneagram
is that if you've got
a story idea that's up and running
and you've worked on dilemma then
that's a point as as you begin to get
into dilemma for your protagonist
that's when it's very useful to look at
the enneagram because the
the character traits of
the type of your protagonist the
personality type
will inform and influence your
insight into the dilemma it can suggest
possibilities it can deepen and
dimensionalize
the dilemma and the way that i
tackle that is that i'll
have that character in mind like derek
and then i'll look at
the one sheet for each of the nine types
and those come
from the um enneagram institute.com
website i work with a slightly older one
sheet
from when i wrote my book around 2006.
it it fits on one sheet of paper and it
has a lot of information
what they have for their one sheet now
is they've expanded upon it
so there's more complexity which is
great
i just like going back to the one sheets
that are in my book writing a great
movie
because it's short and sweet then once
you've worked with that
you'll find the stuff on their website
which opens it up a little more
to be very useful too but what i do is
that i
think i put myself in the position of my
character or i think about my character
the lead character and look at the one
sheet for each of the nine types
and i'll sometimes just use my book or i
often i print out the one sheets because
i've saved them
and i'll look at a type one thinking
about derek and be like okay silver
former
there's some key aspects maybe a couple
on my underline
that's a maybe look at the two go
through that
three oh that has more stuff that's
interesting four has some distinct
possibilities
five and you know and maybe when i'm
looking at a five
well even while i'm thinking about derek
i may notice that wow that could really
be the
the predator who's operating skyler
and it just jumps out at me like wow
there's there's that person
so you're just kind of like going
through
the nine one sheeps nine one sheets
mostly one character at a time but
sometimes other ones will just jump out
at you
and
so i found that i think derek really
seems like a six
and kind of like this you know as you're
looking through the one sheet a whole
bunch of stuff
starts to light up for you and then once
you've
figured out who your main characters are
which type your main characters are even
if you have
a couple possibilities like at first
you're not sure you think
derek might be a four or a six and you
play with that for a while
and then usually your understanding of
it will crystallize after a while where
perhaps you see how derek reacts in a
key moment
and that really resonates with a
tendency of a type
six and then you really see yeah i
really think he is a type six not a type
four
so your gra your understanding gradually
crystallizes at first it's
tentative and you keep the possibilities
open
because you're not trying to force any
of these types on your characters you're
just trying to
listen to who your characters are and
listen to what the enneagram is
saying as possibilities for them which
type they might be and so on
but after a while you will um
your understanding will crystallize and
at that point it's really interesting to
go to the book the wisdom of the
enneagram
which is written by the same guys from
the enneagram institute
and it's a big thick book and there's a
40 page
chapter on each type which takes you
much
much deeper than the one sheet did
and it really goes so
deep into so many aspects of
that character type that it helps you
dimensionalize them
it shows the reasons why these
tendencies are there and why their fear
is there
and the way in which they fall apart
when things
really go bad for them and the way in
which they can
go from being in an extremely unhealthy
reactive state
to a healthy proactive
integration where they they can
[Music]
pull themselves together and become
a healthy aspect of themselves you know
and scripts deal with character arcs so
where
a person's flaws and weaknesses and
disabilities and all that
are either resolved if there's a
creative resolution and they become a
more healthy version of themselves
or they disintegrate and become
you know fall apart completely
in in a tragic resolution
but the uh the 40 page chapter is really
a deep
and complex journey
through the full mechanics of what makes
this person tick
and it really gives you tremendous
depth and dimension and flaws
and strengths and hopes
and subconscious attitudes and
how they react in a bad situation and
how they can
pull themselves out of a tail spin
in certain types of situations so it
really is
very comprehensive and one of the things
that's most interesting about
working with the enneagram is that i've
done it hundreds of times for
so many different characters and
for instance when i'm going through the
40 page chapter
for a character that's maybe a five
maybe i've already
done 15 different characters that are
fives and
really studied them in depth and really
know them well
but maybe one was like a serial killer
in
you know the bombings of ireland and one
is a
you know a schizophrenic baker in
argentina and like completely like
comedy
and so that
the characters come in such completely
different contexts
that when i start going back through
something that i've been through a whole
whole bunch of times
like the 40 page chapter on a type 5
it's like i've never seen it before
because it's completely different
because i'm inhabiting this baker now
instead of this bomber
and it's literally like i've never seen
this stuff before which is so
interesting because i've been
soaking my head in it for years
so it's fresh each time which is great
because
that's what you want when you're
developing characters it's not just
a rehash of people you already know
but a completely fresh discovery from a
completely new character
and you're not only are you
pulling new material out of what you've
already been through
but your facility with the tool grows
and expands each time
so you know you just have more facility
more
ability to understand more complexities
and also the ability to just see it more
simply and clearly like oh it's just
that
instead of like it's all this stuff so
you
you know your your capacity to work with
the tool both
clarifies and deepens into
more complexity because sometimes the
ability to just
see thing clearly and simply is the aha
moment that you've been working toward
maybe for years
in terms of using this tool where you
start to understand
the different personality types
more clearly even if you have to work
hard to get there each time
but you're a little better at it each
time
and yet it's always new that's endlessly
fascinating
okay so that's a good tour through the
enneagram
you